long teams often find it exciting to
surpass human level performance on a
specific recognition or classification
task let's talk over some of the things
you see if you're trying to accomplish
this yourself we've discussed before how
machine learning progress gets harder as
you approach or even surpass human level
performance let's talk over one more
example of why that's the case
let's say you're a problem where a team
of humans discussing and debating
achieves 0.5% error a single human 1%
error and you have an algorithm with 0.6
percent training error and 0.8 percent
death error so in this case what is the
avoidable bias so this one is relatively
easier to answer 0.5 percent is you
estimate a Bayes error so you avoidable
byers you're not going to use this 1%
number as reference you can use this
difference so maybe you estimate your
avoidable buyers as at least open 1% and
your variance as 0.2% so there's maybe
more to do to reduce your variance than
your avoidable bias perhaps but now
let's take a harder example let's say
team of humans and single human
performance the same as before but your
algorithm gets 0.3 percent
training error and 0.4 percent
dev error now what is the avoidable bias
is now actually much harder to answer
that is the fact that your training
error 0.3 percent does this mean you've
over fitted by 0.2 percents or is Bayes
error actually 0.1 percent or maybe as
basil 0.2 percent or maybe Bayes error
is 0.3 percent you don't really know but
based on the information given in this
example is actually you actually don't
have enough information to tell if you
should focus on reducing bias or
reducing perience in your algorithm so
that slows down the efficiency which
usually makes progress
moreover if you're ever is already
better than even a team of humans
looking at and discussing and debating
the right label for an example then it's
just also harder to rely on human
intuition to tell your algorithm what
are ways that your algorithm could still
improve the performance so in this
example once you've surpassed this 0.5%
threshold
your options or ways of making progress
on the machine learning problem are just
less clear doesn't mean you can make
progress you can always you might still
make significant progress but some of
the tools you have for pointing you in a
clear direction just don't work as well
now there aren't many problems where
machine learning significantly surpasses
human level performance for example I
think online advertising estimating how
likely someone is to click on an ad
probably learning algorithms do that
much better today than any human could
or making product recommendations
recommending movies or books for you um
I think that websites today can do that
much better than maybe even your closest
friends can or logistics predicting how
long will take you to drive from A to B
or predicting how long take a delivery
vehicle to drive for me to be all trying
to predict whether someone will repay
alone and therefore whether or not you
should approve a loan operon
all of these are problems where I think
today machine learning faster mass as a
single humans performance notice
something about these four examples all
four of these examples actually learning
from structured data where you might
have a database of what has users of
click on database of privacy board
before databases at home on takes to get
from A to B database of previous loan
applications and their outcomes and
these are not natural perception
problems so these are not computer
vision or speech recognition or natural
language processing tasks
humans tend to be very good at natural
cos so it is possible but it's just a
bit harder for computers to surpass
human of a performance on natural
perception tasks and finally all of
these are problems where there are teams
that have access to huge amounts of data
so for example the best systems for all
four of these applications have probably
looked at far more data of that
application than any human could
possibly look at and so that's also may
that may be relatively easy for computer
to surpass human level performance now
the fact that there's so much data
computer could examine so they can
verify this that's called patterns and
then even a human might other than these
problems today there are speech
recognition systems that can surpass
human level performance and there are
also some computer vision some image
recognition tasks where computers have
surpassed human level performance but
because humans are very good at these
natural perception thoughts I think it
was harder for computers to get there
and then there are some in a medical
task for example reading ECGs or
diagnosing skin cancer or certain narrow
radiology tasks where computers are
getting really good and maybe surpassing
a single human level performance and I
guess one of the exciting things about
recent advances in deep learning is that
even for these tasks we can now surpass
human level performance in some cases
but it has been a bit harder because
humans tend to be very good at these
sort of natural perception sauce so
surpassing human level performance is
often not easy but given enough data
that been lots of deep learning systems
that surpass human of a performance on a
single supervised learning problem so
that makes sense for an application
you're working on I hope that maybe
someday you manage to get your deep
learning system to also surpass human
level performance